Alright, so this week we're talking about morality.
Now, it might seem on the surface that to talk about morality is pretty
straightforward, right? It's right versus wrong.
It's what we should be doing, what we shouldn't be doing, and we're really comparing
that all to God as the standard.
So it seems pretty straightforward it seems pretty simple I mean but I want you to
take a second and step back because it may not be as simple as you
think or as you hope because I want you to think for a minute about really what
we're asking students to do we're asking them to differentiate
between right and wrong and we're asking them to do that when
they're taught that some of these things that we're talking about are just a little
bit more than mere opinion. See, students are taught on a whole different
level than maybe what we're used to, so you're going to experience something that
maybe you don't realize you're going to experience.
When we stand on stage as leaders and we're talking about Jesus and we're talking
about truth and we're talking about these fundamental facts about the Christian
faith and we're telling them what they ought to be doing what they ought not to be
doing. Students can often be looking at us as we're thinking we're talking about
fact and we're thinking we're talking pretty black and white kind of things and that
may not necessarily be the case when some of our students are looking up to us
and thinking well that's your opinion.
That's what you think and I'm not sure if I actually want to agree with
your opinion so this is a good week it's a good time
to take a step back make sure you meet with your small group leaders and make
sure you talk through a little bit about what they might experience in their small
groups and talk a little bit about some feedback that you can get from the students
about some of the things that you're talking about from the main stage about
what their thoughts are on right versus wrong and what they're being taught in
school and how they feel about certain topics.
You might be comforted, but you also might be surprised and you might get some
answers that you're not real thrilled with, but it's a good starting point and
something that you can continue to work through.
So I'll never forget back when I was teaching, I'd walk in in the morning and you'd
be stepping through the hallways and you have to literally step over all of the
students that were sitting in the hallways and talking, all these great
conversations and activity going on in the hallways.
It was a great sort of experience in the morning to see some students smiling faces
and other students not so smiling faces, and it was awesome.
And one day at a teacher's meeting, we got talking about some of the students, and
we realized something that most of us just were completely blind to.
The students were doing more than just sitting in the hallways hanging out.
Well, the students were sitting in the hallways copying each other's homework for
their first class or their first couple of classes throughout the day.
And some of us talked about it and said well are they collaborating and working
together on something? Or are they just straight up copying their homework which
would be obviously wrong.
And so we talked about it, we debated it a little bit, and then we decided let's
confront some of our students. Let's talk through with some of our students.
Maybe they just don't realize what they're doing which would seem strange but maybe
they don't realize what they're doing is wrong.
So we pulled a few students aside with no intention of getting them in trouble and
just said, hey, what are you doing in the hallways in the morning?
And with no regard for possibly getting in trouble or having us to call
our parents or some kind of consequence coming down on them, they just were like,
yeah, we're just copying homework.
That's what we're doing. No big deal.
And so we asked them, well, do you think this is wrong?
And the response was simple. Well, no.
Well, why not? Well, because we just don't.
That was their answer. They just don't.
And if you do a little bit of research into the world of education and what students
are being taught is right and wrong, it's actually becoming more and more closer to
what we consider to be opinion. And students are being taught that anytime we use
words like feeling or what they believe.
It's more about what they think is simply an opinion.
Well, this is sort of causing some problems, right?
Because now when we start talking about things more than just copying homework as
being an opinion, we say things like, well, are all men or all people created
equally? Well, is that a fact or is that an opinion?
What about uh it's wrong in our country to drink under the age of 21
is that a fact or is that just an opinion of somebody what
about killing another unjustly something we all consider at least hope all
consider to be a universal truth that killing another unjustly as in murder is
wrong, then is that fact or is that
opinion? So the slippery slope that the students are starting down is these things
aren't necessarily becoming a little bit more based on opinion.
So then when we get into things like same-sex marriage, fact or
opinion. So as you stand on a main stage or you stand in front of a group of
students and you start talking about what Scripture says is fact.
They are being taught that these things are often just opinion.
So talking about morality is vitally, vitally important in terms of helping
them establish what our moral compass actually is and where we get our morals from.
There's a little story I like to tell when it comes to morality.
It's a story about little Johnny.
And little Johnny is the little first or second grader that gets an assignment from
school to go home and measure how tall he is.
And he fumbles around his house, and he's trying to figure out how to measure
himself so he can go back to school and be a huge success and get a great grade and
all those wonderful things. And he scrambles all over the house, and he can't figure
out anything. And finally, he has this massively beautifully wonderful idea, and he
runs to school the next day, and all the little boys and girls are going up to the
front the class and some say you know I'm this tall according to my dad and I'm this
many basketballs high and you know all these other different objects and johnny gets
up in front of the classroom and big smile beaming says I am one Johnny tall
and the teacher you know kind of looks at him and sort of reacts and johnny
didn't pass the assignment because johnny has we have no idea how tall
johnny really is because johnny will never be more or less than one johnny tall no
matter how big Johnny actually gets in the future.
See, we can't use ourselves to measure ourselves.
We need something beyond us, something external to us, and morality functions the
same way. And what's beautiful about morality, as much as it's difficult to follow
what God desires for us to do, the fact that we have morals, the fact that we
understand right from wrong helps us see who God is, points us to God, gives us
evidence for God, because we need something beyond ourselves to understand what the
difference between right and wrong is.
So what can we do, right? So there's a lot of cautionary there.
So what can you actually do? Well, the first thing that you can do is approach all
of this, first and foremost, with grace and with love.
Remember, most of your students, I hope all of your students really, are just trying
to love their friends and love people, and be tolerant, and get along, and live
peacefully among everybody else.
I'm sure that's the case with almost all, if not all of your students.
So they're not trying to be malicious.
They're not trying to necessarily defy authority.
So approach them with a tremendous amount of grace and a tremendous amount of love
and listen. Listen to the reasons that they're giving.
That doesn't mean don't challenge those reasons, but make sure that you thoroughly,
thoroughly listen to, you know, why they're saying what they're saying.
Secondly, know where they're coming from.
Talk to them about where they're hearing their ideas.
You know, which classes even? Which teachers?
Is it at home? Is it online? Is it TV and media?
Where are they getting these ideas from?
Now that doesn't mean you don't want to tell them all your ideas are stupid.
You just want to hear where they're from and hear again why they believe those
things and why do you think those things are true and help them work through what
those thoughts actually are. No different than helping us, you know, you guys
working through all of these topics and answering great questions and asking more
great questions and trying to figure things out.
You want to help students navigate this a little bit rather than just shoot them
down. And finally, don't be afraid to challenge their thinking.
Some students might come at you a little bit.
Some students might get a little bit aggressive.
Some might just shut down inside themselves if they feel like their opinion is not
valued or not being heard.
That's okay as long as you draw that back out of them and don't get offended if a
student kind of comes at you.
Challenge their thinking, but do so again in love and in understanding and by
listening and taking the time necessary.
And make sure that this is communicated to your small group leaders because in that
context, in that community, in the community that you are trying to build within
your youth groups, it is so, so important that those students feel like they can
open up and they feel like they can offer that opinion and be accepted but also
be challenged.